um your chair of your party group on the
menopause why is it important that we
talk about this more well 51 of the
population 13 million menopausal women
in this country and only one for 14 of
them are getting the support and the
medication they need we've got to do
better that women are given up work
women are walking away from marriages
domestic violence increases suicide
increases by 16 amongst menopausal women
and it's all down to a lack of knowledge
and the lack of services it's so easily
remedy Sophie so you talk about the lack
of knowledge and I think this is quite
important isn't it because you can't get
help unless you know what it is you need
to get help for that you're going
through it do you think people are just
missing the signs of it well I'm a
classic example of that in that I mean I
thought in 2010 I was having a nervous
breakdown I ended up on antidepressants
stayed on them for eight years believing
in mental health problems became an MP
was talking about menopause in the House
of Commons and how we needed to do more
for women didn't acknowledge that I was
menopausal because I didn't link up the
the other symptoms I just looked at the
anxiety and the depression I didn't
think about the restless legs the dry
eyes the migraine the itchy skin the
aches and the pains I just thought that
was part of being a woman and getting
older once I embraced it I went on HRT
I'm 20 years younger that's exactly
definitely that's extraordinary isn't it
and do you think it's because everyone
just experiences it differently
every woman's menopause is different but
there's such a lack of knowledge around
what the menopause is and that is
something that we can work with and we
can look after and we can get women
through it and women are wonderful they
will survive anything we know that but
the menopause is something most
definitely we can survive and thrive
from um it was really interesting
because I was reading some of what you
written about your own experiences
saying that you didn't realize that
you're in the menopause
um and saying that you were very tired
you're having to push yourself at work
and you said
um I used to love going on holidays
places like Florida even the thought of
going to the local park was too much I
just enjoy it just didn't do it I mean I
came up with so many excuses not to go
on holidays and
I'm away all week when I come home I
want you know I do want to be packing a
case going holidays any excuse not to
have to venture out of my safe Zone but
I could I knew how far I could push
myself I could walk up the stairs
halfway stop carry on the rest I'm a
completely different person I've been
taking ownership I I've owned my
menopause and you say it went on HR HRT
why do you think
people are reluctant to use it because
there was a really bad study that came
out about 25 years ago which said that
HRT could cause breast cancer what they
never told us is that 20 women develop
breast cancer those 20 women actually
had breast cancer in the family so the
chances are they were going to get it
anyway but a lot of the doctors haven't
forgotten that a lot of women haven't
forgotten that so there's a massive
piece of work needs to be done about
re-educating people on the safetiness of
menopause it's also a brilliant HRT
prevents other conditions like
um dementia heart disease there's so
many things that when your hormones go
you are going to get more of and also if
it improves your quality of life that is
I can't tell you the difference it made
to me and every woman I speak to says
that once they take control of it their
life is transformed and now you
published a report at the end of last
year with recommendations for change
what do you think needs to happen
everything that's in my report whatever
I say that you need to swap my menopause
needs to happen and I will not stop
until we get to the point where we're
not asking for women to have special
treatment we're asking for women to have
the opportunity to be normal they'll be
given the respect and the consideration
in all areas of social policy that
actually acknowledge that menopause is
preventing women from working it's
causing women to be on long-term sick
it's causing women to be an
antidepressants women women women
Women's Health need I say more Sophie no
you don't need to say anymore that that
will do just fine thank you so much for
being on the program this morning it's
been really great to talk to you a very
powerful advocate for uh that cause in
particular